23 years ago, Atlanta native,
an architecture and urban planning
student, Ryan Gravel, had an
experience that opened his mind
to what urban living could be.
My senior year, I spent abroad
in Paris and lived
without a car for a year, traveled
by train everywhere, and within a
month of arriving, I had lost 15
pounds. I was in the best shape of
my life because I was walking
everywhere.
Paris fundamentally changed the way
that I understood the construction
of the world around me, and
I got obsessed with the role of
infrastructure as the foundation
for our economy, it's the foundation
for our social life and for our
culture.
For his master's thesis, Gravel
sketched out a plan to make Atlanta
more like Paris.
He proposed redeveloping the land
along the city's historic rail lines
to create a 22-mile loop called
the Atlanta Beltline.
He proposed turning the city's
abandoned industrial areas
and single-family neighborhoods into
business districts and walking
trails.
And he proposed connecting downtown
to the rest of the city, all
with a new train running
along the entire Atlanta Beltline.
Never imagined we would actually do
it, but just wanted to graduate.
But they did for the most part.
Cathy Woolard, who was president of
the Atlanta City Council, read
Gravel's thesis and decided
to use it as a blueprint to remake
much of the city.
Today, the Atlanta Beltline is a
walking and biking trail, parts
of which are bordered by retail and
condos.
But one piece of Gravel's grand
vision didn't get built.
The Train.
Today, gravel runs, co-working, and
event space along the Beltline,
which also serves as a gathering
place for urbanists interested in
making Atlanta less dependent on
cars.
He says that the train line is
essential for improving city life.
Those early days when we built the
movement behind the project, it was
around transit.
The three COVID relief bills set
aside $69 billion
in federal funding for local transit
agencies to operate and add
to their transportation systems,
meaning that Atlanta might finally
get its train with many American
taxpayers who will never step foot
on it, picking up much of the tab.
Many American cities have used
federal money to build rail transit
lines that suffer from dismal
ridership, that are expensive to
maintain, and that are a major
drain on their budgets.
Buses don't have the aesthetic
appeal of trains and don't evoke
the dense pre-automobile 19th-century
esthetic that many urbanists
romanticize.
But they're far less costly and
more convenient.
And commuters generally prioritize
modes of transit that get them from
point A to point B
with the least amount of hassle.
The sharp decline in the number of
workers showing up at an office
every day post-pandemic makes
building commuter rail an even worse
use of public funds, says Baruch
Feigenbaum, senior managing director
of transportation policy at Reason
Foundation, the nonprofit that
publishes Reason TV and Reason
magazine.
You do need a public transit
network. It's absolutely true, but
it's the quality of the network and
not the actual mode that matters.
So there's been a major change
that we've really not seen
since pre-World War Two days.
And that change is overwhelmingly
negative for transit, especially
rail transit, that we're seeing rail
ridership at about 40%,
maybe 50% of pre-pandemic
levels, and bus ridership at
60 to 70%.
And I think most people would tell
you if transit
ridership overall gets back to 80%
of pre-pandemic levels, that would
be a wild success.
Most people do not think that's
going to happen.
11 years ago, Feigenbaum wrote that
the proposed Beltline train was
possibly the worst transit project
of all time.
I think it's amazingly still true.
And the reason I say that is
because it's very
expensive and it doesn't connect
people from point A to point B.
People don't go on transit
from one's house to another one's
house. And that's basically the only
places that this rail line served.
And so there was no clear ridership
for this train.
So they came up with these kind
of East-West side lines
that they said, well, you're right,
there's not any destinations on
this beltline, but we're going to
build these other lines, and then
people are going to take them.
And so the two problems with that
are, one, more expensive
in order to build these lines and
they had not identified funding for
the first big circle, not to mention
these other.
Two, every time people
have to make a connection or have to
change lines, you lose ridership.
A lot of politicians like Rail
because they say it's permanent and
we can't change it.
And ok that's true,
but sometimes you want to change it.
Gravel says that the emergence of
restaurants and the thriving Ponce
City Market along the Beltline
demonstrates that when you build new
infrastructure, commerce gravitates
to it.
Ponce City Market is a major
destination.
All these buildings being built
across the way: some of the best
architecture in the city, some of
the coolest places to build, some of
the best companies to work for.
You know why this area?
Because of the Beltline. They're
there for other reasons.
But also the Beltline.
We're building a future city.
And look at it, proven by the
last 22 years, it's getting built
in front of our eyes.
The best time to start transit is
ten years ago.
The second best time is now.
Matthew Roush is the chair of
Beltline Rail Now a
group of activists pushing for the
completion of Gravel's vision.
Because it's never getting less
expensive.
We're talking about one-time
investments in the life of a city,
and because they're more expensive,
means we need to go and figure out
how to get more money.
But rail isn't really a one-time
investment.
While Rao's coalition wants the
federal government to foot much of
the bill for rail construction,
local taxpayers are usually
responsible for the majority of
operating costs for all forms
of transit.
In 2020, transit fares
for light rail and streetcars
covered about 14%
of operating costs nationwide.
Getting federal dollars to build
rail is kind of like being gifted a
swimming pool that you barely use
and then being left to cover the
maintenance costs.
It might have sounded like a good
idea.
There is some local enthusiasm for
the rail project.
Atlanta voters approved a half-cent
sales tax in 2016.
That, in part, was supposed to
fund the construction of the
Beltline train.
But the city's public transit
agency, known as MARTA, has been
using that funding instead
to improve current operations,
especially bus service.
The agency's most recent analysis
projected that it would cost an
estimated 287 million
to $448 million
to build just the first three miles
of track.
That's up from $172 million,
which was the estimated cost just
three years ago.
We're here in L.A.
to look at bus rapid transit
to see how we can transfer the best
practices back to Atlanta.
MARTA wants Atlanta to emulate the
bus service in cities like Los
Angeles that have dedicated bus
lanes and synchronized stoplights to
minimize traffic.
Bus lanes cost far less to maintain
than rail, and their routes are
modified if demand rises for false.
Several studies have found that
people who can't afford cars rely
on buses more than trains.
And MARTA recently abandoned a light
rail project in favor of bus
rapid transit, saying it would
provide greater mobility for far
less money.
People rely on what they have, and
that's what we have.
There's nothing wrong with buses.
Buses are the core of
any city's mass transit
system. What we're talking about
here is a different kind of project
that is higher in capacity
and creates also
a beautiful place for everyone in
the city to access.
Atlanta residents don't have to look
far for an example of a streetcar
like the one the coalition wants to
build on the Beltline.
They already have one that stretches
2.7 miles through the downtown
area, and this is what it
looks like on a weekday afternoon
at about 3 p.m.
its average speed is about five
miles per hour, about the same speed
as the horse-drawn railways that
crisscross cities, including
Atlanta, in the 19th century.
The streetcar stops every quarter
mile. Less than a thousand people
ride the streetcar daily in a
city 500 times that size.
It cost more than $52 million
per mile to build in 2013.
The ridership on that is pretty
low.
So it's dismal.
Yes. So what?
What makes you think that this is
going to be different?
I think the success of
any transit project
is taking people from where they
are to where they want to go or
need to go. We'll be the first city
and only city in the world to have
this.
This multi-purpose trail,
this greenway, and
the transit within it, and
connecting to our existing heavy
rail system.
Even if ground broke tomorrow.
MARTA estimates it could take five
years to complete just the first
mile and a half of track.
There's a good chance that transit
ridership will never fully come back
post-pandemic because so many fewer
people are commuting to jobs.
Even in New York City, paid bus
and subway ridership is at 55%
of its pre-pandemic levels
nationwide.
Transit ridership is at about 69%
of what it was before COVID.
Rail transit nationwide has taken
a particularly bad hit,
with ridership decreasing by almost
50% between 2011 and
2020, while nonrail
transit decreased by about 30%.
That trend applies in Atlanta,
where MARTA's bus ridership
decreased by 39%
post-COVID, while rail decreased
by about 62%.
Before COVID, only 5%
of Americans' working days were
spent at home.
Researchers at Stanford analyzed
poll data and concluded that now
about half of Americans work at home
at least once a week, and about a
quarter are fully remote.
The pandemic also accelerated
the decade-long trend of Americans
moving from cities to lower-density
suburbs, including the area
surrounding the city of Atlanta,
which saw population loss in its
urban core for the first time
in a decade between 2020
and 2021, Rao says
it's just a blip.
This corridor, which is half a mile
wide, will contain between
23 and 25% of
the population of this whole city
by mid-century.
And that kind of density will
only work sustainably
if we provide the transit.
Downtown Atlanta is booming.
You have more freedom if you can
telework so people, they go where
they want to go.
I know that's surprising for a lot
of people, but people do want to be
downtown. They want to be on the
Beltline. They want to be here.
There's so much to do.
You can walk.
You can ride scooters.
You can ride your bike.
I walk the Beltline practically
four times a week.
It's pretty integral to my life.
I like the skateboard and
just have fun and be drawn.
While Ponce City Market is a popular
destination, much of the loop is
still a nature trail with nothing
but single-family homes around it.
Gravel's master's thesis opens with
a history of Atlanta transportation,
pointing out that streetcars were
profitable in many American cities
before they were displaced by roads
and cars.
Is that something that you think
we can ever get back to, where
there could be an actual, you know,
profitable streetcar?
It's a good question.
From my personal viewpoint,
I think I think there's a shared
good that comes with public
investment and transit.
And so I'm fully supportive of
public transit.
But like the military,
like highways, like all kinds of
things, there are there are things
that are good for all of us that we
should be investing in collectively.
This wasn't always the case.
In the 19th century, urban transit
systems were privately owned and
operated.
Companies would sometimes lose money
at the fare box to encourage
ridership but make it back by
speculating in land that increased
in value because of the new train
station.
When local governments did build
infrastructure, they would sometimes
pay for it by levying special
assessments on land owners who
benefited.
Rouse Coalition is proposing just
such a special levy along the
Beltline, but it would cover just
10% of the projected $2.5
billion construction cost.
Federal taxpayers would foot 40%
of the bill. If the local
stakeholders who stand to benefit
from increased property values had
to foot more of the bill.
Maybe they would think twice.
While rail and city buses
consistently lose money.
Buses that move people between
cities are still privately owned
and operated at a profit.
Amtrak, on the other hand, loses
close to $1,000,000,000 annually
and relies on federal subsidies.
The bill I'm about to sign
a lot is proof that despite
the cynics, Democrats and
Republicans can
come together and deliver results.
It makes the most significant
investment in passenger rail
in the past 50 years
in public transit ever.
Feigenbaum says many politicians
seem to care less about whether
transportation projects are best
serving their constituents
and much more about the spectacle.
If I'm a politician and
I'm running for reelection, I
get to go to a ribbon-cutting
ceremony and say, I did this
and I get to send out a postcard to
all of the voters in my district and
say, I did this.
I'm here working for you, using
your taxpayer money in dubious ways.
Whereas if you're
talking about operations so there's
no ribbon cuttings with operations,
it's not sexy, it's not something
you can sell saying, Oh,
your bus is coming every 5 minutes
as opposed to every 8 minutes gets
a real yawn.
In a political type environment.
Atlanta's rail advocates say that
MARTA's decision to allocate the
money from the tax levy on improving
bus operations defies the
will of voters.
What we're about is making sure
there's transparency and
accountability and what our public
officials and public institutions
are doing with the money that we're
giving them to achieve
an outcome.
And if there isn't enough money to
build the projects
that MARTA said it could build for
the money we said we would pay
then I think it's up to agencies
like MARTA and our leaders at the
city to tell us that and
to give us the opportunity as
to how to react to that.
There was a package of things.
The Beltline was one of the things
in the package, and there were other
things in that package, including
increased bus service
and making sure that there was some
better technology on the rail lines.
We really don't know, and I
don't think they know why
this passed.
And I should also note that there
has to be some ability
for a transit agency to make
some types of minor changes when
a major world-changing event
like COVID-19 happens.
You know, MARTA didn't know
that COVID-19 was going to happen,
and they certainly could not have
projected what changes were going
to happen as a result of that.
The two COVID relief bills, one
signed by Trump, the other by Biden,
sent $69 billion in
additional funding to America's
transit agencies at a time.
When ridership is falling.
This country for basically as
long as you and I have been alive
has been under-investing in
rail.
Pete Buttigieg, is, of course,
running for president.
And so he's going to say things that
a politician would.
If you spend more money on rail
projects where they're not needed,
which is most places in the country,
you're going to be wasting your
money. I think if Pete Buttigieg
would go down a couple of floors
in the DOT building and talk to his
transit planners and his folks
who have been there for more than 5
minutes, he would realize that
this doesn't necessarily make a lot
of sense. It means you're going to
have fewer bus lines that you
need because spending money on rail
is inherently going to take money
from bus.
It means you're going to have fewer
transportation resources that you
need, probably roadways, but
could be other things such as bike
lanes and sidewalks.
You're going to be spending funds
that you just don't
need in an economy that is already
overheated.
Buttigieg has been a critic of how
cars reshaped the national
landscape.
He said that the interstate highway
system is systemically racist
because it cut through historic
black and immigrant neighborhoods.
If a highway was
built for the purpose of dividing
a white and a black neighborhood,
or if an underpass was
constructed such that a bus
carrying mostly black and Puerto
Rican kids to a beach
or that would have been in New York
was was designed too low for it to
pass by. But that obviously reflects
racism that went into those design
choices.
You can question whether we
should have built the highway system
in the exact form that we did.
I think those are all fair
questions. But this idea that
somehow we spent a lot of money on
highways and so now it's time to
spend a lot of money on railways
because that's just the right thing
to do or that's just going to solve
our problems, magically, doesn't
pencil out.
Buses, replace rail, not
because of conspiracy, but because
they're much more flexible
and cost-effective.
Transit should cater to what
customers want, which is fast
and
convenient, point-to-point mobility.
Reimagining what transit
is, which is it's not just
an agency, it's services
that are provided to
your customers, which are people who
are paying for it.
And so we're not just talking about
fixed rail and bus.
We're talking about the Ubers
and Lifts.
We're talking about on-demand
transit. We're talking
about micro-transit, which is
transit that isn't travel on a fixed
route. It might go based on where
it's needed. We're talking about
vanpool.
We're talking about sort of a
concept of mobility
that might not, in some cases,
involve people owning cars, which
is okay if they don't want to
own a car.
And we have a system that works for
that. But I think that type
of approach is going to be
much better than forcing people
to give up cars because we make
it so difficult to drive.
Paris's walkability is what
first inspired Ryan Gravel
to re-imagine the Atlanta cityscape
in the late nineties.
Today, Feigenbaum suggests looking
to France for a different lesson
about mobility.
France, which is not exactly known
for being a free market capitalist
capital.
The private sector operates all of
their transit services, and it's
much better.
You'd also need some type of
vouchers to make sure that
the lower-income folks who are the
most dependent on transit can
actually access that and can reach
the jobs in other places that they
need to go.
But I think this is the time we need
to start asking those questions,
because in the wake of COVID, we're
not going to get back to the
ridership we had in 2019,
and the ridership we had in 2019
wasn't that good anyway?
Is there a sense in which,
you know, the American city is just
different from a city like
Paris and or can't
graph that onto a place like
Atlanta?
Do you worry that you are
kind of fighting an inevitable
growth pattern?
No.
Not at all.
I'm not worried about that at all.
You know, Atlanta is not Paris,
Atlanta is not New York, Atlanta is
not Houston.
You know, like Atlanta is Atlanta.
And Atlanta needs to grow in the way
that it grows into the best version
of itself.
Atlanta's history is railroads.
Its future is also railroads.
MARTA still hasn't committed to
building rail on the Beltline and
says the issue still needs two
more years of study before the board
can vote on it.
The rail advocates we spoke to worry
that by then it will be too late
to qualify for federal funding for a
project that's taken more than 20
years already.
Gravel is right.
The rail lines were good for
American cities because they were
heavily used and often profitable.
So what are the chances
that today a project expected
from the outset to operate at a
loss during a period of declining
rail transit use and that depends
on over $100 million
in federal subsidies is
going to be something that Atlanta
commuters actually use?